Donald Trump initially reacting to the
indictment with a misspelled Post in
which he says he has been indicated not
only is this the first time that a
former president has been indicated by a
grand jury this is the first time a
grand jury has indicated any president
and of course it is beyond parody that
even this Trump can't string together a
reasonable statement about Trump posting
to truth quote these thugs in radical
left monsters have just indicated the
45th president of the United States of
America and the leading Republican
candidate by far for the 2024 nomination
for president here he engages caps lock
and says this is an attack on our
country the likes of which has never
been seen before remember Trump was a
one-man crime spree as president the
likes of which the country has never
seen before